- I want you to give me some suggestions
what you want a rap about.
- [Attendee 1] Blueberries!
But, one second,
(audience laugh)
- The number one, number
one, the number one rule is,
it can't be too easy.
Now, if you think blueberries is-
- [Attendee 2] Toboggans!
- Sounds good
Then that's good.
Okay, one.
Let me get the second rule out.
(audience laugh)
You can be as creative as possible.
You can say, fucking, you
can smash things together.
You can be like, "A day in the life
of an Aztec high priest."
That's the best suggestion ever.
He was a German man, who
said it, that's the accent.
So, so far, over there
we have blueberries,
and you said, "Toboggan."
(audience vocalizing)
What is the difference
between a toboggan and a sled?
- [Attendee 3] Nothing.
- [Attendee 4]] Neither.
- [Attendee 2] Probably blades.
- Probably blades?
(audience laugh)
Cool.
Yeah.
Nah, I'm down with that, yeah.
Blueberries and toboggans,
let's ask people over here.
What do you want to rap about?
- [Attendee 5] Trump's manicurist.
(audience laugh)
- Trump's manicurist.
Okay, is this a news story
that I've neglected to pay attention to?
Or are you just smashing words together?
(audience vocalizing)
You said he has soft hands.
Okay.
- [Audience] Small hands.
- Small hands?
Okay, cool.
- [Attendee 6] Small hands.
- Do you not reckon he
has soft hands as well?
(audience laugh)
He looks like a motherfucker
with soft hands.
(audience laugh)
- [Attendee 6] No he doesn't!
- Say what you want about
his rhetoric in politics,
but I think his hands are pretty smooth.
Okay, so Trump's manicurist.
Let's come to you guys
in the dark corner here.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Attendee 7] Orgasms!
- Well, you're not in
that corner, are you?
(audience laugh)
(audience cheer)
"Actually, I'm a very skilled
ventriloquist, Christopher."
(audience laugh)
What do you wanna rap about?
- [Attendee 8] Hippocampal atrophy.
- Oh!
Oh! A real teacher's pet here.
(audience laugh)
Hippocampal atrophy.
So the hippocampus is a part of the brain,
not a college for large
African land mammals, okay?
(audience laugh)
Thank you, dads in the corner.
And atrophy is
when something kind of
shrinks and ameliorates.
So hippocampal atrophy,
is that related to things
like dementia or what?
What, brain kind of
disease is that related to?
- [Attendee 8] Epilepsy.
- Epilepsy? Ah, good to know,
Thank you very much.
Cool. So hippocampal atrophy.
The man over there who shouted,
"Orgasms", is very upset.
(audience laugh)
I said, "Orgasm", then she
was like, "I'm a doctor."
(audience laugh)
So, blueberries, toboggans,
hippocampal atrophy,
and what was yours over there?
- [Attendee 5] Trump's manicurist
- Trump's manicurist.
And then people over here, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Attendee 9] Public toilet.
- Public toilets, great, thank you.
(audience laugh)
No, that's a good, that's
a good little suggestion.
What do you have a favorite public toilet
or least favorite public toilet?
(audience laugh)
(audience vocalizing)
You don't have to have one.
- [Attendee 9] Cortland Park.
- Cortland Park, do you say?
(Attendee 9 laughs)
Okay.
- [Attendee 9] It's a nasty one.
- It's a nasty public lavatory?
Nasty as in you can meet
some pretty freaky individuals there?
(audience laugh)
Give you a treat, that person knows.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
Well this then lovely
people, is a freestyle,
that's a rap made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions,
those suggestions to remind you,
public toilets, blueberries, toboggans,
Trump's manicurist, and
hippocampal atrophy,
which is to do with epilepsy.
I'm so glad you explained that.
(audience laugh)
And do not worry it's not going
to be anywhere near as bad
as you're expecting a privately
educated, middle class
British boy to be.
I chose you a quite chill
beat cause it's Sunday,
and I thought let's not get
too cray, but I can't help
how you'll react so let's have fun.
(audience cheers)
♪ Want some fruit, want so
many, not a big banana ♪
♪ Want a punnet of the
berries that are blue ♪
♪ I walk to the market and
choose an organic one ♪
♪ And I never even chew, I
just knock 'em right back ♪
♪ Like Skittles or M&Ms ♪
♪ Once you get organic ones,
you never pick 'em again ♪
♪ They're too expensive,
I'ma mush 'em in a smoothie ♪
♪ I like to get the blueberry you need ♪
♪ Any type with the skin and the vitamin ♪
♪ When I eat a lot, yeah
I might invite them in ♪
♪ Like vampires, yeah I
spot them on the horizon ♪
♪ On my toboggan like an
Eskimo when I flow on snow ♪
♪ Different to a sled and
the man knows, he's like ♪
♪ Chris, I would be dismayed
if you said a toboggan ♪
♪ Was not displaying the blades ♪
♪ I'm like, okay, to
me it's real thriller ♪
♪ Toboggan with the blades like
the vampire killer, get it ♪
♪ That's Wesley Snipes and we like ♪
♪ When I'm over in the
Arctic Circle I hike ♪
♪ Right there to the North Pole, my goal ♪
♪ Get a dog sled, and I just run through ♪
♪ Seeing people on the edge of the snow ♪
♪ And I'm like, my toboggan's
better than yours, bro ♪
♪ When they pick on me,
and you start to spoil it ♪
♪ I'll be pissing on the
ice like a public toilet ♪
♪ Making that yellow, I'm a mean fellow ♪
♪ If you wanna go to Cortland
Park, take care though ♪
♪ You gotta get there early ♪
♪ Once they're clean,
in the afternoon dirty ♪
♪ And I'm so certain, I've got one wish ♪
♪ I just want a clean
place that I can piss ♪
♪ So I do, yeah, I choose
leaves, unzip right there ♪
♪ Hang loosely upon the
roots of the trees ♪
♪ In the park, in the green,
if you wanna number two ♪
♪ Then you're outta luck team ♪
♪ Gotta go in there, raise the seat ♪
♪ Gotta hover right
over it, it's the tree ♪
♪ Gotta get big glutes, and
the thighs and it burns ♪
♪ You shit before you go
to the park, better learn ♪
♪ Don't eat any bad burritos ♪
♪ Otherwise it's running right through ♪
♪ And you need those public toilets ♪
♪ That'll spoil your picnic ♪
♪ If you've got a problem in your brain ♪
♪ Better kick it, go and see that ♪
♪ Like specialist, you're
like, I've got a disease ♪
♪ That could be easily missed ♪
♪ I start fitting, start
seeing flashes of light ♪
♪ I'd be falling on the
floor, not feeling upright ♪
♪ I'm not making light of the situation ♪
♪ Let me get an MRI, no hesitation ♪
♪ Put me on the scanner,
magnetic resonance ♪
♪ With all the imaging, got a large head ♪
♪ And they still be fitting in ♪
♪ They look in on my
hippocampus, so pretty ♪
♪ Looking at the slides of the brain ♪
♪ All the activity they say, yo Chris ♪
♪ We can see you thinking when you rhyme ♪
♪ And your hippocampal area is shrinking ♪
♪ Say doc, what you saying to me ♪
♪ In the layman's terms, that's atrophy ♪
♪ I say, oh, I'm so surprised ♪
♪ I never thought that my
brain would be atrophied ♪
♪ Like a little sultana,
a tiny little prune ♪
♪ Or a dehydrated blueberry,
there's not enough room ♪
♪ For that to do that, yeah I'm a purist ♪
♪ I use tiny Thai women
for my manicurist ♪
♪ I be walking into the
salon, I show them my hands ♪
♪ And they're like, they're so long ♪
♪ Put out the fingers, large phalanges ♪
♪ And this guy's skin looking so orangy ♪
♪ I say, whoa man, you're a big lug ♪
♪ Six foot four and he's like, I'm Trump ♪
♪ I say, yeah, I thought
I recognized you ♪
♪ That's a nice little
color that you did choose ♪
♪ On your little fingers ♪
♪ I don't understand ♪
♪ Do you pay less because
you've got smaller hands ♪
♪ I can't fail to vote if
you've got tiny nails ♪
♪ Down to Mar-a-Lago
I know you've bailed ♪
♪ When you're in bed
you're not a charmer ♪
♪ You can't get it up with Melania ♪
♪ Don't mean to talk
about this, yeah opened ♪
♪ Up a chasm between
the left and the right ♪
♪ But no orgasms ever happening
when Trump's right there ♪
♪ He be down between her legs, big hair ♪
♪ Looking like a little
wig bobbing up and down ♪
♪ Melania's from Slovenia,
she's like, I frown ♪
♪ Why don't you please me, no satisfied ♪
♪ After one hour no,
I've still not arrived ♪
♪ And so, what does she do ♪
♪ Yeah, she broods ♪
♪ Go to the kitchen and get some fruit ♪
♪ And she starts to eat that ♪
♪ And he's still licking ♪
♪ A real fruit eating habit no kicking ♪
♪ Anyway, that was dirty ♪
♪ And it spoiled it to give
you images as horrible ♪
♪ As Cortland public toilets ♪
(audience cheer)